and you should see links below you
should see well icons below to the
social media sites so let's go Queens
gambit will it be accepted or declined
that is the question
okay it is Queens gambit declined slob
defense with move three Knight f3 Knight
f6 very common and so far we are in the
same position as my latest video the one
that I uploaded to my youtube channel
just before I began this livestream
where I was playing white against pot
sir with an exciting finish with an
exciting finish I'll leave it as that if
you're interested in checking it out
Bishop here I and now in that game D
take C was played I played a4 as a
response so I could play my knight to
the center and I think that that's a
good idea
this is one thought 95 if I'm there's
another candidate moving I'm considering
its Queen to b3 since this is now a weak
point after the Bishop is developed what
else
I'm not sure what else to do there's
queen bee three there's ninety five
these are the two that I'm considering I
hear hits the bishop yeah I'm gonna do
that
85 and then yeah I think this is working
out this might be a very very difficult
road ahead for black because I think
okay well that's interesting I think
this is the correct follow-up I think
what in this position I think that if
Queen b6 is not the move played there's
some serious problems that are going to
well black is gonna have serious
problems because Queen c7 runs into
moves like Bishop f4 and also just like
the idea of rook c1 and the C file
eventually opening up the Queen would be
accessible from the c7 square and now
with wit wit this move with this move
what's going on the light squares have
been weakened c6 a6 this Bishop when it
played back to h5 and here's a important
point in response to the Knights
pressure on the bishop if it had played
the f5 the bishop is still in a spot to
maybe come back and defend these light
square weaknesses c6 and a six but after
having played to h5 the bishop is saying
you know what I'm not going to just I'm
not going to be around here to defend
any light squares so I'm trying to
somehow make use of this diagonal my
bishop getting here would be great and I
think going here first is the correct
step doing it at this very moment as
well before black has the option of
playing to e6 excuse me
playing east six and then me
C takes D with eat takes T and then it's
not so well I can't get a piece there so
easily can I at night or a bishop or a
queen or make use of this diagonal so if
the if the knight captures I could build
a Center efore with tempo and well I was
seeing like if if if Knight takes e4
Knight takes Knight I was thinking Queen
here is mate but it's not the bishop is
around to watch over f7 so what is black
dude there's only two good recaptures or
to want two ones to be considering at
least I don't know if they're both good
it's either the night of the pun if the
knight takes then the center has been
given up if the pawn takes the center
hasn't been given up but I have the b5
square again that's it's available to me
so that's the little thing that black
will be needing to weigh in this
position do I maintain my Center and
give the b5 square or give up my center
and recapture with the knight my knight
and watch over the b v square and
apparently the verdict is you know what
let's just give that up let's give the
maintain the center and then deal with
whatever happens with peace coming to
this square maybe I could give a check
right away I think I think playing here
is good and then following up with my
Bishop move I want to have my Bishop
contributing in some way and with this
move I'm threatening to take and then
maybe take here although there are some
issues as soon as I do take here the
pond recaptures and is hitting my knight
even if here's another thing that you
can be falling back on in your own games
of course in your own game I don't know
I have to keep saying that
I guess just for a a little bit of
emphasis when you're on your own and
having to think through things
worst case scenario now for white is eat
well even if I can't make use of this
diagonal really soon
I'm still in a good spot because I'll
have a nice structure I have my dark
square Bishop ideally placed and by
ideal I mean outside of my eventual
structure pawn on e6 darks for a bishop
at least seeing the black side of the
board and the pieces are in good spots
so what about this I could take the
knight if the Queen recaptures then
there's very annoying checks that would
occur so I'm assuming after I take care
pawn captures as best I think that's
just unnecessary I think I just play e6
and now this is a very difficult move to
me I think a6 might be needed now just
from a simple move just just by having I
think that I think the start of the
trouble was maybe the bishop playing out
to g4 if it does happen to be aligned I
think black is really needing to know
exactly what to be doing as those next
few follow up moves a6 is played okay I
could give a check here with my queen
what has been weakened as a result of
that move what is it doing what is it
not doing it's watching over b5 what is
it not doing it's not watching over b6
and it's currently hit once defended
once I think hitting it again is a good
idea so that's what I'm gonna do I
didn't want to be a bit cautious about
this Bishop coming out to give check
because this Bishop is controlling these
two if a bishop lands here could turn
out to be mate in some crazy position
but um I think it's I think it's quite
alright right here this Knight is in a
pin like if you could imagine this night
not even on the board and this Queen not
even on the board
oops this Bishop coming out here to this
square is main to be a little bit
cautious to this diagonal but I think
it's all working out there
Oh what else well I don't know what to
suggest for black because I think
there's trouble in all variations okay
well maybe that is best interesting v5
hmm Bishop takes pawn takes Queen takes
with check I think this is working out
I'm gonna do it
tactics I'm in a spot to eventually land
a fork on b6 after a bunch of smoke
clears with check the knight can't block
it has to be the other night and after
the night plays here I chop here on this
square I'm no longer also having to
worry about a bishop playing here I have
the f1 square available now that my
bishop has moved so I think the right
idea here is to first take this knight
take here a couple times and then end
with a fork although my knight might end
up getting trapped actually it is gonna
get captured back and my opponent will
have the bishop pair so this is
interesting
bishop check oh oh the king wait there
the king should have gone somewhere else
I think let's just go somewhere else and
let's just lock it up King is gonna be
good here and my rooks just just keep
pushing this pawn play it's super safe
here super safe where has the time gone
where is that time done time burners
forks everywhere push these pawns push
them keep pushing give checks free moves
they're down on time okay
got crazy a flurry of moves right at the
end there good game let's hit that
rewind button and take maybe one or two
things away from this hopefully let's
see from your perspective you're playing
the black side a different move to
consider I've seen Bishop f5 I think it
comes with the loss of a pond or a
compromised Queen side structure you
really really really need to be cautious
of white reacting with the Queen to b3
move after you've moved your after you
move your Bishop be cautious of the
White Queen reacting with Queen to b3
pinpointing the one weak square
beware of b7 as soon as your Bishop
moves and this turned out to be a
problem I didn't play there right away
I centralized my knight with tempo and
this becomes very difficult i I don't
know I think maybe Queen b6 is the best
way to put up resistance but you're
you're gonna end up with doubled be
pawns and I don't know if it's enough to
just have play on the a file with having
doubled be pawns I know it is much
different however if you have BB pawns
but they're still as a group or another
one it's not isolated what could happen
if Queen b6 is played is that I could
take you can recapture and then after we
take a couple times on this square this
C pawn becomes a deep on and the beak
buns become double isolated which is
usually very bad and I think I think
there's a way to exploit this and I
don't know you could really be making
great use of this half opened a file so
I'm really questioning in other words
I'm really drawn back to what I'm drawn
to this this move right here the
decision to deploy the light square
bishop you could consider this instead
if you're looking for I think it would
be worth your it's about a 15 min
video if you went to youtube.com slash
chest network you're gonna see that that
is the one currently being played right
here out of this opening I had the white
side my opponent a strong player played
D take C which is a line it's considered
the Queens gambit declined Slav Dutch
and that was actually news to me that's
actually what the EC o is saying of the
particular line that ended up being
played
I think there's well I think there's
more moves to to go before you could
actually call it that but anyhow D take
C and then only later Bishop f5 was
played D takes C sometimes you'll be
seeing a four that's a pretty common
move also I think 95 but a four is a
move that's pretty common so look into
this maybe take on this square and then
think about Bishop here you'll notice
the difference if you capture on this
square and I play a four after you bring
your Bishop out I don't have this Queen
beat three stuff anymore you have a pond
currently on c4 it's not available so
anyhow that's a couple quick points I
think you're really on your heels from
this point on so I think things are
coming back to the light square bishop
decisions anyhow just some quick things
to achu on there and hopefully you're
benefiting from those words that I'm
sharing on that okay you are saying
thanks again and you are welcome okay
let's uh let's get another game in here
another one coming up coming up coming
up
I want to point out one other thing I
want to point out one other thing from
that game that was just played let me
bring it back up
in this final not the final position but
right here you could end up with the two
bishops versus my rook I was focusing on
the opening because that's where I
obtained a I believe a clear advantage
but right here after this move play your
king - right here King to c6 what did
you do you played your king up play your
King to c6 so you have this bishop check
available King c6 Knight takes rook
Bishop check King here is forced roof
takes knight and at least you have the
bishop pair versus my rook and pawn
actually our rook and two pawns excuse
me I would be looking two pawns versus
your your Bishop hair so that that's
going to be best right there but we were
in a time scramble right there whirling
anyhow that was one last point so okay